this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
[Laughter]
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists who the hell wants
to be famous
oh man apparently everyone well there's
nothing wrong with being well known for
creating something meaningful
it seems like influencers think that
being famous is the point rather than
the byproduct today we're speaking with
nick bilton director of the new hbo
documentary
fake famous as well as chris bailey one
of the film's stars about
the perils of pursuing fame clout
and attention in today's insta world
gentlemen thanks for joining us
thank you for having us thanks for being
here y'all that's good i gotta tell you
man i felt like i wasn't watching a
documentary when i watched this i felt
like i was witnessing something
you are you are you are definitely
yeah it's uh it's well we didn't know
what was going to happen when we started
the whole thing so uh should we tell the
listeners those let's talk about this
why make a film about fake fame
so i had uh i'd been a reporter the new
york times for 15 years and then went to
vanity fair
as a reporter there and graydon carter
who was my editor
at the time was also doing some
documentaries for hbo
and he'd approached me and uh he said oh
you know we should do a doc
on uh influencer culture and how
powerful it is and i and i said
it's it's [ __ ] and he's like what do
you mean i said well i could make an
influencer in 10 minutes and he said
well that's a great film
and and then i had to actually try to
figure out how to do that
and uh and so we uh what we did is i i
teamed up with
this producer annabelle dunn who's done
a bunch of films before and and we
we held a casting call uh in la we we
actually kind of wanted to copy the
flash dance
you know vibe um and we we
literally just put out an email to some
casting sites and said
do you want to be famous and if you do
show up at this place the only
requirement was that you had
you know a thousand followers or less we
didn't want anyone that had a large
following
we had 5 000 people respond in 24 hours
uh and we narrowed it down to a few a
few hundred that showed up
and then we narrowed that down to we
were originally going to do two people
we ended up doing three and one of whom
is
chris bailey sitting right here and um
and they all had around a thousand
followers each and then i started to buy
them
fake likes and fake comments and fake
followers
and we started to do fake photo shoots
all with the goal
of making them to be perceived as being
famous to see how their lives would
change
and uh it sounds a little bit reality tv
but it was
reality tv meets documentary meets you
know
kind of a social experiment yeah yeah it
was quite the experiment and i noticed
chris the reason i
wanted you to be here today is you
really stood out among everyone
there there are a few reasons um they
were asking you during the sort of
casting call how many
how many followers you have you're the
only person who said i don't know how
many followers i have
and then the other thing that he stood
out about him was when we asked everyone
do you want to be famous
uh um and um and people had these like
[ __ ] answers they were like
yes so i can make the world a better
place and yes so i can change the world
and and solve world peace and world
hunger
and chris said i still remember this he
said
i don't want to be famous and we all
stood there we were like what did he say
and he goes
i deserve to be famous i'm gonna be
famous and it was like whoa that was a
refreshing answer
yeah remember that yeah i do i do
because i've seen everybody freeze in
the room yeah we were
it was great i mean it was a cool answer
it was like a okay
um yeah an honest answer yeah
i feel like out of the three main uh
participants in this experiment
like i feel like you chris were probably
the most genuine and i won't i'll try to
not give the whole documentary away
but i just remember a certain point in
the documentary you were like
yeah i don't i don't want these fake
comments like i want people to like me
for me
not because of this this bs that we're
kind of putting out there and yeah i
really admired that man
my favorite line in the film was was one
of chris's when you said
i wrote it down here i'd rather be broke
and real than rich and
fake yeah right and so talk a little bit
about that because there was
i mean the whole idea of this was like
let's make you
famous but what nick what you did was
sort of
bring out the absurdity the fakeness in
fame in general
now there are sort of two types of fame
there's this fake famous there's the
aggregating eyeballs getting attention
attention seeking
right but then there's this other thing
where where it is
you're well known for doing something
well and it seems to me
chris what you wanted to do is the
reason you wanted
quote unquote fame is because of your
talents not just because you wanted
more attention that's right yeah um i
just think like
like right now especially
uh a lot of consumers
confuse fame and ability
and talent you know because they don't
know how to differentiate
between the two and when people think
about fame the first thing that people
think about besides having a platform is
being rich
you know what i'm saying but your life
can be rich without having all of that
being famous comes with a lot of
[ __ ] yeah so
um you know luckily i've been blessed in
life to see a lot a lot of things that
a lot of people wish they could see but
i've gotten to be around it
and i understand everything that
all the consequences of like really
being a famous person like
do you want to be famous for a good
reason you know do you have like a
message for people like
what's the point right you know and some
people think that fame
is the point and i noticed that in all
of the sort of
the the casting call that you did nick
there there was
this uh you even had this scene where
everyone said i'm a model and an actor
i'm a model and an actor i'm a model
it just kept popping up right and so
what is it because to me and i think to
many people
we are simultaneously attracted to that
but we're also like turned off by the
the vapidity of the whole thing
well i think fame itself has is has been
destroyed by
you know fame is a construct of the of
media it's a it is a result of screens
and squares and that are everywhere and
i think
back in in the in the 20s it served a
purpose there were people who
were truly talented for being behind a
camera
and uh and for singing or whatever it
was that they did and there was only
you know back if you if you go back to
the 1920s there was a couple of hundred
like a-list famous people you know uh
and
and i think that and and even if you
fast-forward to today there's only a few
thousand people who are legitimately
famous because of some sort of
television talent or
or basketball or whatever it is and i
think what happened as a result of
social media is it
well first reality tv came along where
you could just be famous for no reason
and and it's the fakest of all fakeness
and then along comes social media where
you could be famous for that number
which was what we were trying to kind of
point out in the film and
and i think that the the problem is is
that you know there are
millions of people with hundreds of
thousands of followers
that no one knows who they are they're
not famous they're just people
you know what was really interesting is
is one of the people in the film
dominique who we got to
we ended up getting her to around 350
000 followers people would like look at
her
social media and they'd be like are you
famous right and the fact that you have
to ask that question
it's just so ridiculous yeah like you
should know if the person
if you know the person if you don't and
um and i think that
you know what's what was really
interesting was we had these three
different people who all took three
different routes
you know dom was like i i'm gonna ride
this to the to the moon
and wiley who i'll save that story you
can watch it on the film but
right and then chris he was like i i
don't want this and
um you're a little frustrated by that at
first at first i was because
i because we wanted to do some of the
shoots and things like that but
but then i like i got to a point where i
was like i actually respect it like it's
like
you know i think i do i think it's a
harder journey absolutely but i think
it's the more noble one
yeah you know right yeah i mean i think
like
it's uh um and i think you know this
there's no right or wrong version of it
i think what
what was frustrating to me was realizing
the impact
that um that
social media has had on kids today you
know the studies that show 87
of kids want to be famous more than
anything else on the planet
more than anything and this is the
longitudinal study that was done at ucla
where
they looked at kids who were in their
um you know back in the 1960s and they
said what do you want to be when you
grow up and the kids were like i want to
be an astronaut i want to be a
lawyer or a doctor or whatever a bus
driver you know and then by the 80s it
was i want to be a
basketball player i want to be a
musician now it's
i just want to be famous right
insta-famous and that's it and what is
it about that attention
that is so enticing the the attention
of other people that we don't even know
it's like what chris said it's like
it's like this [ __ ]
belief that oh fame equals happiness and
money and so on and it's just not true i
mean every
look at like look at the billionaires
that that
just in the past you know john mcafee
this week committed suicide in jail
um because and he was worth hundreds of
millions of dollars because he was about
to be extradited
you know jeff bezos has gone through
such a midlife crisis
that he divorced his wife and five left
you know his five kids
is now going to risk his life to go on a
rocket ship so he can beat elon musk
to get to space elon musk has been
divorced three times
and his look at his twitter feed you can
see how completely [ __ ] up he is bill
gates just got divorced like
there's this [ __ ] ideal that you
think oh i have money
and fame i'm gonna be happy these people
are [ __ ] miserable
yeah they're miserable and i think it
you know
it's that this it starts there and it
goes all the way down to these people on
social media
yeah for sure no i think it's
interesting because when i
like i don't crave to be famous i mean
we have some kind of you know some type
of notoriety
notoriety because we have documentaries
on netflix and
every once in a blue moon someone will
stop me and oh hey you're that guy from
the minimalism documentary
but for me it's like if you're doing
good work
if you are an actually talented person
like that's what comes first and then
the fame is kind of a result it's a
byproduct
of of hard work and of talent where
yeah having that goal of being famous
well what did rogan say he said uh
rich and famous people are the most
miserable people on the planet and
everyone's trying to be one of them
that's true
yeah it's completely true yeah um yeah
so it's
and and i think that you know when you
when you look at the
film and everyone all the people that
wanted to be in it and so on
uh it just showed how many people are
trying they think that that's
their goal to to happiness i think
what's interesting
about chris was i mean there was one
thing that was interesting so we were
doing these fake photo shoots
and chris was like come and film me silk
screening yeah and
and it was like i was like that's not
the point but
at the same time like for him that was
the point right you know and i think
it's like and you're
like you didn't you sell every did
everything sell out when the film came
out or something like that all the
one-off stuff
oh wow that's great that's awesome
awesome i think that's the
you know that must have been a
yeah more fun experience than getting a
thousand fake followers exactly yeah i
didn't need the followers they don't
have any i don't need fake followers
they have no money
what do i need them for they're not
actually going to support me it's just
an illusion
to make you think that more people
that's what's enticing has any
has any of your has have any of your
habits changed as a result of the film
or anything like that have you like do
you use instagram less or do you take it
less seriously
or well since we're on that topic and
we're with the minimalist
i just bought this thing i think i think
it's a it's a minimalist
uh purchase okay uh i don't know if you
guys are hip to it it's called the light
phone
oh yeah oh yeah yes
so yeah answering your question is
okay i'm getting to the point now where
i don't like the fact that people feel
like they can just like
access me at any time like let me just
send this [ __ ] a dm and see if
he's gonna just respond and like
wait do you have the light phone with
you no i'm waiting it's
like late june or something or it
shouldn't be coming any day now
but um i was i don't know
somehow you know the phone be listening
to you and i was probably complaining
one of my boys like dude i'm
sick of this [ __ ] and the phone starts
showing me this thing
and i'm like oh this is interesting
because i'm like oh it don't have like
all these apps and all this dumb stuff
like i could just get on the phone
talk to i want to talk to listen to
music and leave me the hell alone you
know what i'm saying that's what i like
you know yeah and um so yeah my habits
have changed because i'm a little bit
i'm trying to like preserve like the
privacy that i have right now while i
can
because i know that it's just like it's
rolling momentum it's growing
and people become more interested and
more interested over time the more
things that i do
but i'm like i'm i'm really i'm i'm a
private person
i'm not going to you're not going to
know all my business no matter what
right so do you use instagram less
i'm trying to use instagram less and
less every day
yeah it's hard you know you guys on
instagram yeah yeah yeah we have someone
who manages that though
do you guys you know sit in bed at night
and scroll through this
i don't i don't sleep with the phone in
the room right i put it in a different
room
um yeah i don't have the app on my phone
i think that's the
i mean but that and all of a sudden that
takes it out of your world right now
having social media on your phone takes
it out of your world
what's been really interesting for me is
so i wrote a book on twitter in 2013
about like the rise of the company and
all the backstabbing and infighting and
twitter has been i've been on it since
essentially day one
and i got to a point recently well
i've always had been to the point where
i just love and hate it and i got to a
point where i hated it more than i loved
it and i deleted it from my phone and
don't really check it anymore right i
don't miss it in the slightest
yeah i literally don't miss it in the
slices
you feel like you need it and then you
remove it and you realize how
not only do you not need it but part of
it was making you
miserable yeah yeah because i felt like
on like an app like that i
like i'm just talking to myself yeah and
i'm like yeah i'm
i'm wasting all the gems that are inside
of my mind and then i'm like
these people don't even deserve this and
i need to figure out how to express this
in a more constructive way than
type it on a computer where i only have
like 140 characters it's limiting me
anyway
so like right i was like yeah twitter is
pointless
you know but everybody all my friends
were like dude you need to get back on
twitter now
because like i was talking real [ __ ] on
twitter but
i was like i said i didn't feel like
anybody's listening or like
reading it or you know like it's a lot
of noise and it's hard to break through
that noise i have
i have the opposite problem where people
are paying attention
to what i would say and then berating me
for like because if that's your problem
anything anything you know writing
your id like i wrote a piece this week
about the space race between bezos and
musk and like all these like music fans
came on twitter
because i somebody had sent me a couple
of the tweets and i was laughing at it
but
they were like defending ilama i'm like
he's the richest guy in the world like
you don't need to [ __ ] defend him
right right
get a life get a [ __ ] life yeah i
look at social media like it's a fake
world
it's like we are allowed to curse on
here right yeah okay
or podcast channel bleep it out but
either way yeah you feel free to talk
freely
but you know like twitter for example
all the trolls on twitter
like they would never oh they would
never to your face they would never talk
i have an interesting story about this
this is such a fake world go for it so i
was covering a trial when i was in the
new york times covering a trial in new
york and
when you're in the courtroom you don't
have access to your phone
and the journalists are all all squished
off to a side and i was sitting
with a woman i won't mention her name
but um
and she was lovely just we spent three
weeks together
uh and um and at the end of it i flew
back to la
and and there was a few people i had
like become friendly with
lunch and coffees and whatever in the in
the courthouse i didn't have my phone
and i was like oh let me go follow all
these people so i'd start following them
all and this one woman
uh had blocked me and i spent three
weeks with her there was like it would
be like it'd be like i was hanging out
for three weeks and then i go to follow
you and i
realize you've blocked me on social
media yeah and i was like what and so i
grabbed my wife's phone
i looked up her account and i was like
well my wife's not blocked and so i
searched
my name on there and all she had done
had spent
uh like weeks berating me calling me
every name under the sun
but had sat next to me like my best
friend yeah and it's like
in person it's i mean it was like the
ultimate fakeness
that's exactly that is what social media
is in my opinion yeah that's exactly
what i'm trying to say like yeah it's it
is it's
it's a fake world in fact like with
facebook i got off of facebook
back in 2016. smart because what i
realized was hey it's a fake world like
people don't actually talk
in real life the way they talk on
facebook uh but on
on its best day facebook pacified me
like it was it was entertaining on it's
on the worst day it would ruin my day
and i had a lot more worse days than
best days so yeah i got rid of it but
yeah it's unbelievable that's crazy
because she wouldn't block you in real
life
no she's just completely nice to me yeah
but on social media
she had that super power yeah i've had a
lot of people
that things like that have happened but
i'm all for blocking people
especially blocking people in real life
though like like
right removing people from my life who
are toxic right right and
and but i feel like that's the case with
social media and they feel like it's
that there's like a a tech guru
i know who once said to me um that
technology makes the world 51 better and
49 worse and because we get that extra
one or two percent
it's worth it i think with social media
it's the other way around i think it
makes the world at least 51
worse than 49 better yeah and as a
result
i don't want anything really to do with
it and it's like
you and and the algorithm is so good
that it's not like he figured out what
he wanted the light phone yeah you know
and you can't beat the algorithm and the
only way to beat it is to not play the
game
not participate yeah i heard a story
about the the algorithm figuring out
when
someone was pregnant and sending them a
bunch of
direct mailers and so their family found
out she was pregnant
before that she even announced it to the
family
well what's an interesting thing so
chris had just said that he had
mentioned that he was getting fed up
with
his phone and then he started to see
these ads so a lot of people think
that the ads are a result because your
phone's listening to you
it's actually more terrifying than that
it really is so the reason that they
know is because
the data and the algorithms see patterns
of people who start to do certain things
and like things differently or less or
leave comments or more
or search certain things on social media
or on google and so on
and the the data can figure out oh this
person is getting a little fed up with
their phone uh we're going to serve them
up this ad
right here and so that's how it knows
which is even more
terrifying because it's not listening to
you it just knows every single solitary
detail about you it's how good the
algorithm is
yeah wow that's unbelievable well this
is a listener driven
show on the maximal chris i do want to
talk to you about the one-off project
and a bunch of other stuff but right now
let's get into some questions we have
someone from
instagram who asks a question it's fake
all right uh this is uh libby why do the
people who just
post photos of themselves in skimpy
outfits
and pouts get five million followers yet
the people who actually have something
meaningful to say
get only a handful of followers i'm not
i'm not pouting enough on instagram am i
you're not wearing the yoga pants
i bought the yoga pants for you just so
we can get up our instagram follower
account oh my god
yeah guys uh there's something
fascinating this question because there
is a sort of moralizing in it as well
it assumes that like the
skimpy outfits are immoral or bad or
whatever but
um while it might be empty or even tacky
um clearly it's what a lot of people
want
well but the reason is because the
entire internet is a dating website like
that's it every aspect of it you think
like
you know bumble or whatever is is are
the dating i
no it's facebook it's instagram it's
that and the other and
of course sex sells like that's you know
i mean i don't know chris what do you
think
i think people like looking at ass
that's what i mean yeah i mean it's true
you can't you can't deny it so they show
ass and
people like it and they get the likes
and they get the followers right
just because something is enticing and
it attracts eyeballs onto a car crash
also attracts eyeballs
well what's interesting is i remember
it's funny you bring this up because i
was
um when we were doing a bunch of
research for the dock we were looking
for
we were looking for influencer accounts
so we could emulate them and copy them
and if you go look at any of these
bikini clad
accounts whether it's men or women there
will be one photo
of a sunset or a cappuccino or a chair
on the beach or something where they
where they took the picture because
it was their they felt artistic at the
time and they wanted to express this
picture
and the bikini photos get a million
likes and that chair picture or that
that sunset gets like a hundred yeah and
it's like
and you can tell they're trying and
they're not going to delete it and it's
and it's but i also think like part of
part of me thinks like well you should
do more of that and say
screw you to the people that are only
going to like the naked pictures of you
and like force them to look at some of
the things that you want to
document that you see as artistic yeah
yeah it's unfortunate that a lot of
people influence or specifically yeah
what drives their photos
it's the likes so they're catering to
their audience rather than
catering to themselves completely chris
what have you seen what are some of the
most obnoxious things you've seen people
do on instagram or social media to
attract attention or fame what makes you
cringe
oh man i hate when people go in public
places
and do things for the gram
i really i don't like that at all
like um okay so i have an example i was
recently in new york city
and i went over there to see
um cause shows called what parties said
brooklyn art museum
anyway i've been a big fan of him for a
long time a lot of my life
as an artist so anyway to see this
big presentation's crazy because he has
all these like statues and they have
like all these emotions
and a lot of them are like they some of
them look like they're crying and some
of them
are like sitting down and like these
certain poses and this is like the uh
this is like the the what everybody
knows him for
these like they're called companions
okay and there's people
in this museum and they're like
clearing space in the museum so that
they can sit down and like
emulate this [ __ ] sculpture and then
take a picture of it
so that they can put it on the gram but
when i'm looking at you do it i'm like
bro you this is not a good look
like you look so terrible right now have
you ever seen that artwork where
they there was someone who uh removed
photoshop photos out of people's hands
in scenarios like that
so if you have the couple lying in bed
next to each other but like they
then you take the phone out you just
look like you're staring
you're a crazy person yeah you're
staring at your hand right
same thing if you were to remove the
phones from that scenario
yeah those people would look inside yeah
if i filmed it from my
point of view oh my god you'd be looking
so lame
like people would be like bro you really
went over there you bought a ticket to
do this
like what's wrong with you like yeah or
when i'm just
in a place and i see that people are
like taking the most like basic photo op
i guess like like that pink wall i
didn't understand that before nick took
me over there but then
i realized places like that are all over
la those uh those things with the wings
on the wall
i hate when i see people trying to do
that like i'm like dude
stop yeah he's like stop taking pictures
it's become so cliche well it's
interesting it's interesting because the
pink wall
yeah tell me about that because it's
right down the street from here yeah and
and ever what it's a pink wall why and
every time i go buy it there are
17 people taking photos in front of it
yeah 17 is a low number
yeah well uh that's a slow day
um it's one of the it's so that there's
a the paul smith
store in la is uh is a big
pink rectangle of a building that they
painted bright pink
and they did it not not be not for
social media
but they did it because they thought it
would look cool and it's kind of like
you know a paul smith thing to do
yeah and it has become uh at one point
the number one tourist destination in
los
angeles wow a flat pink wall and and
what's really interesting
is if you notice when you drive around
la now there are dozens of pink
stores and there's a sneaker store on
melrose it's painted themselves pink oh
yeah there's a target
uh a place next to the target down on
beverly that painted itself pink there's
a donut store
over on highland like all these stores
have now painted themselves pink with
the hope that people come to take a
picture and then
buy a donut or some sneakers or
something like that and it's um
it's crazy it's just it's i mean when we
we went to film there for the opening of
the film there's this like fun sequence
where we shot and
on a slow-motion camera people taking
selfies and jumping and so on and so
forth
and uh and we would like we had to get
releases from everyone for it
and people would be i mean there were
there was these women that had come from
england for an instagram vacation where
they get driven around to all these
different places to take selfies there
were there was a guy who was driven
yeah yeah instagram vacation instagram
vacation it's 2 000
or something like that they put you up
in like a a
condo in glendale because you don't know
the difference and then they drive you
around
for a week to like the pier and the pink
wall
and the wings that chris has mentioned
and like you take a bunch of pictures
and that's it and
there was a guy that we can't that came
a young kid 14 years old who
had driven from like four hours away
just to like come
with his parents to come take a picture
it's like it's crazy
yeah it's totally crazy it is we have
another question here from
justin in college station texas
how do you involve minimalism and
mindfulness
at work this is something that i am
trying to deal with and
i'm just curious how you incorporate
those things
while you're at work all right so justin
is a social media manager
and really i mean this is something
that's difficult because
as part of your work for both of you
you are required not required but you
feel as though you're required to be on
social media to some extent
and so it's always about finding that
balance of misery and
and contentment right so so
how chris how is that manifested in your
life where you
you you feel as though you're compelled
to post something as part of your
business but also
it's might be driving you crazy at the
same time um
yeah so recently this started to become
a thing for me uh basically what you
guys are talking about
and my friend who she be like
uh she like she'd be hanging out with
like these instagram
influencer chicks and doing all the
pictures and doing all and making these
girls look cool basically
and uh so she's always she's known me
for like years
and she's like oh you would be just big
on this you would be you would blow up
on tick tock you would do this you
you could do that and i'm like
then do it do it for me then
you feel me because like i am i'm just
this way
i'm not trying to be this way so it's
very difficult for me to like try to
catch
everything on this phone and then like
post it and feel like okay like yeah now
i've done my part for showing
but when you get your so when you get
your light phone do you imagine that
you'll
have your instagram to post your your
your fashion
and then you'll kind of just put that
phone away at night and just have the
light phone or how
are you yeah so actually i'm trying to
find somebody who's going to do that
stuff for me because
i'm my job is just to make art that's it
and i'm not doing anything else
and that's the way it's going to be so
i love it i don't need to do that like i
will pay you
that's fine yeah you know yeah and
that's just the way that i feel i i'm
i've been able to spend more time
working on things
that are actually worth looking at
through a screen you know what i'm
saying and so now i'm like
this is pretty much what i care that
people see like everything else i'm like
whatever you know
my friends are always taking photos of
me and we're always
thousands of pictures of me around in my
phone but like
i don't feel like i need to post all the
time because as soon as you post then
you're on the phone
you're right you'll be on the phone for
30 more minutes it sucks you right into
it
yeah so i'm trying to trying to not i
think this is something that everyone
struggles with you know everyone goes
through this experience
they you know you get to a point the the
the end
point of it is when you delete the app
from your phone
and then you're in it's almost like you
know quitting drinking and then you're
you're like i think i can have a drink
and you download it again and you're
like
oh yeah i can do this for like five
minutes a day and next thing you know
you look at your phone stats
and you're like and the thing that's so
frustrating for me is
i i love reading books and i write books
and i love reading novels and i could we
i could sit here and talk for
days about my favorite books and writers
and this that and the other
and when i think back on the 15 years
i've wasted
on social media i can't tell you
anything that had an impact on my life
wow nothing it has just been a complete
and utter
[ __ ] wash see i'm i'm somewhere in
between
i agree with you i think fundamentally i
agree with you but i've connected with
so many people via social media
but it always everything that has been
meaningful from it
has extended beyond social media yeah i
mean look i've connected with people
absolutely and and made
friends and so on and so forth but i
don't do that anymore
i don't require that to meet people
anymore i
meet people out and about and i think
that what's been interesting to me post
pandemic
is um i and maybe this maybe it'll be a
reset and we'll just go back to
all staring down on our phones but the
times that i've been
out socially to like dinner parties or
parties or whatever
i the there are almost no one is staring
at their phone like they used to
they're more talking to each other in a
way that we used to before
phones were the the center of our lives
and i think
i think like we spent so we spent a year
and a half being stuck inside staring at
a device that we are like now
saying okay like i don't want to [ __ ]
look at that thing
right everyone i know is going through
that everyone i know is trying to
get their screen time down and and you
know
and leave their phone downstairs when
they go to bed and all these different
things
this term zoom fatigue i've heard but
social media fatigue it's a real thing
did it burn you out during the whole
process of this because they were
they were heaping fake followers and
likes and all the stuff on you i could
tell there was a frustration in you
chris
um like i don't know i don't know that i
was like really that frustrated as much
as i was like i thought it was like very
like funny you didn't get frustrated
that you couldn't tell
who was liking your stuff anymore
leaving comments
yeah i couldn't tell who was actually
paying attention
to what i was doing versus just like the
illusion that was being created right so
it was uh
yeah parts of it were frustrating but
like
more than anything i was just like i was
entertained by it for a little while you
know i was like
okay this is like different you know my
phone is just going crazy all the time
and anytime i get on instagram it's like
hundreds of notifications and i'm like
it's cool until you understand that it's
not
real yeah like ain't nobody trying to
talk to me all right
you know what i'm saying like so yeah
like that was
i think that was the that's the
frustrating part is when you
come back to reality and you realize
like
this ain't uh changing anything in my
actual life
you know what i'm saying not right now
you know so like in the whole process
leading up to when the documentary came
out
like nothing changed you know like
i think maybe one person asked me
something about it
you know and i was just like yeah you'll
see you know you'll see what it's about
right and uh that was it but for
but that was for dominique who was the
other woman on the
in the film like everything changed
everything changed but she's been on the
cover of magazines
she's got like sponsorship skills now
she was a
she worked on the floor at lululemon and
is now an influencer for lululemon like
it's like you know it so i don't know
it's like
i guess for certain people it works and
certain people it doesn't but i think
that
you know i think at the end of the day
the
the whole point of social media is to
deliver ads to you
that is it there's nothing else beyond
that i don't care how many times mark
zuckerberg says he wants to connect
people
it's full of [ __ ] it's all about
advertising
and and i think and you you use it for
free because
you are giving them your data to serve
up those ads
and uh and i just i think i don't know
i'm at the point where for me it's like
it's 40 51 worse than 49 better and that
means
it might even be higher than that it's
definitely higher right it's definitely
higher than that yeah it's interesting
because in the documentary you talked
about
you know the what the reality was of
social media
but how uh it's convenient for
it not to come to light because a lot of
it's dependent on this
fakeness it's a lot of it is dependent
on um yeah people
projecting them fake selves and yeah
it's all it's all a number what's it
what's been interesting for me is like
for through my career is i remember in
the beginning of twitter like your goal
was like i gotta get more followers so i
can get more people to read my articles
and buy more books and so on and so
forth
and now i just could give two shits like
i literally
i went on clubhouse twice and
i don't even i like literally was like
nah not interested
like i have thousands of followers on
there i just do not give a [ __ ]
yeah yeah like snapchat i remember like
just being into it for five minutes and
then being like what the [ __ ] is the
point of this and then like i do like
snap i think it's
one of the best of social media
platforms and doesn't get enough credit
because um evan spiegel is really tries
to not make it about
addiction like he really puts an effort
forth to make it
like when he sees an aspect of the
platform where people are getting
addicted he
they kill that okay which is really cool
um and
uh and it's like he's trying to create
this place that's like safe for kids
um uh but the other ones they're just
yeah and tick tock is this whole other
world oh god as a 40 year old man going
on a tick tock
it's like oh slowly back i mean there's
some creative stuff happening on there
with dance and so on and so forth
yeah it is i believe that and i'm sure
there are artistic ways to use it
effectively but also well i think chris
touched on a good point here we now feel
compelled and people are now telling us
this is what you're supposed to do
you're supposed to use that
in fact i do want to talk about children
we got a lightning round question i'm
going to save for
the maximal because first we need to get
some to some of these listener comments
and
tips check them out hi this is katie
from outside philadelphia
i'm calling in reference to episode 176
where you talk to colin wright about
uh the un-american dream and i believe
it was
ryan who is saying he eventually wants
to build a house that's totally off the
grid
and i believe this information would be
useful for
him and any of your listeners who are
interested in the same
thing there is a organization called
earthship
biotecture and it is headquartered in
arizona
but there is sections
across the united states and they
specialize in building
houses made out of recycled materials
such as
tires and plastic bottles and they are
all
totally off the grid and
environmentally friendly hey guys this
is rachel calling from newport beach
california
i was calling in as a tip for how to
responsibly invest in purchasing a home
without being tied down to a particular
city
this has been a concern multiple callers
have discussed recently and i wanted to
share a solution that has worked
really well for my husband and i in
southern california many homes are at
least a million dollars which would make
it really easy to get in over your head
or not purchase homes using the dave
ramsey guidelines for a sensible down
payment
what we have chosen to do instead is
utilize an investment company to
purchase homes out of state in
affordable markets that have been vetted
with a reliable company
by purchasing rental properties in
different states and ensuring we put
down a large percentage we have built a
lot of equity and cash flow through the
years
this is an excellent solution for anyone
like myself who lives in an
unaffordable housing market but still
wants to purchase real estate
responsibly
the company we've used to purchase our
three properties over the past decade is
marshall reddick real estate
they have been an amazing resource to us
and are totally honest
offering a ton of free education and
training in their website
there are also other companies out there
that do the same thing for us this is
how we've been able to invest in our
family's financial future without making
irrational decisions purchasing a home
in an overpriced market instead of being
a slave to a mortgage we can't justify
or feeling stuck in a certain place
we personally rent and let our
homeownership out of state pay for
itself with tenant rents
i hope this tip helps some of your
callers as it's helped us
all right y'all big thanks to nick and
chris for joining us today they're going
to join us a bunch more over
on the minimalist private podcast this
week patreon.com
the minimalist but real quick for right
here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists ryan
we have time we have a new book coming
out next week
a week from today love people
use things because the opposite never
works yeah j shetty said the minimalists
show you how to disconnect from our
conditioned material state and reconnect
to our true
essence love people and use things this
is not
a book about how to live with less but
about how to live more deeply
and more fully heck yeah now you and i
are going to do a tour stop for anyone
who pre-orders the book you get to
attend
our free virtual tour stop now
eventually in the in the fall and the
winter we're going to do some physical
tour stops but
right now we're doing a worldwide event
yes
we're going to come into your house like
santa claus all in one night
yeah you could uh join us in your living
room
yes indeed the minimalists.com tour you
can find all the details there if you
pre-order the book
all you have to do is upload a receipt
from wherever you got it whether it was
your local bookstore or
amazon just snap a photo of it upload it
there free tour stop we're going to have
erwin rafael mcmanus with us that's on
july
13th at 7 pm eastern if you can't attend
the live event don't worry
it will be posted for at least 48 hours
afterwards so you can go back and watch
it at your
leisure for our added value segment this
week ryan we gotta we'd be remiss if we
didn't talk about
chris bailey who we were just speaking
with we're gonna talk to him a lot more
about
his side project here it's called the
one-off recycled garment project well
you know what's funny is like we don't
typically uh you know propagate clothes
right like we don't we don't say hey buy
this clothing brand or
check out this clothing company but yeah
i think this is the first time we've
ever
done something like this but really it's
not a clothing company i mean
this is this is an art project exactly
and it's beautiful
yeah it's called last one left the
website is oneoffproject.com that's the
numeral one
one off project.com it's also a one-off
project on instagram social media etc if
you want to see what he
is up to but it it is literally it's
recycled clothes so it's one
recycled garments but then he does his
own artistic
spin with it he's not a fashion designer
he's an artist whose medium
happens to be clothing yeah and he puts
together some of the most fascinating i
mean
you even saw what he was wearing today
if you're watching the video on youtube
but you can take a look at what he is
doing and these are all one of one
pieces
talk about artwork work of art
oneoffproject.com by the way
we have a bunch more surprise questions
this week like what moral
responsibilities do social media
platforms bear for the damage they're
inflicting on the young
and the impressionable do successful
influencers
ever experience a feeling of contentment
or
are they always chasing are they always
on the hunt
for the next best thing in what ways is
social media contributing to the
objectification of women
how can we use technology without it
draining
our attention plus a million more
questions about craving
achieving creativity and much more with
nick
and chris and if you want to hear all
that join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week
visit patreon.com the minimalist to
subscribe and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app you're not
just getting
our private podcast i mean you are but
you're also joining a community over
there so what we're really asking you to
do is
join our community you can interact with
people who are also supporters of the
podcast you keep this podcast
a hundred percent advertisement free but
you can also comment and also there's an
entire community section
over there on patreon where you can
interact with all of our
other patreon supporters the true fans
the vips the private podcast supporters
all over there patreon.com
the minimalist you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com
the minimalist if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple sunday writings for free
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com and if you leave here
today with just
one message let it be this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'd be fine
without it